let's think about who bears the burden
of attacks in different situations and
in this video we're going to focus on
insulin and insulin is interesting it's
what's needed for by diabetes in order
to maintain their blood sugar level so
for them you can almost imagine it they
need this just to survive it almost has
an infinite marginal benefit for them so
they're willing no matter no matter what
the price they're essentially willing to
take the insulin that they need to take
so for example even if the price of
insulin were a dollar if the doctors in
this town say collectively all the
diabetics need 3,000 vials a year they
will take 3,000 vials a year if the
price is $80 a vial they'll still take
3,000 vials a year so within reason
within a reasonable price range you have
no change in quantity demanded so in
this state case at least in a reasonable
price range the the demand curve for
insulin is vertical obviously if we went
up to prices like 9 million dollars per
vial then all of a sudden some insulin
some diabetics just won't be able to
afford it and all of a sudden the curve
wouldn't be able to be vertical anymore
but at least in a reasonable price range
you have a vertical curve so this right
over here is our demand curve that is
our demand curve and you might remember
when we talked about elasticity this is
perfectly inelastic demand so it's
perfectly inelastic perfectly inelastic
and the way you could think about it I
kind of think of a brick it's perfectly
inelastic no matter how much you push or
pull on the brick within reason at least
with my level of strength
you're not going to D be able to deform
the brick and that's the opposite of a
rubber brand which is very elastic or
you can think about the definition of
elasticity the one we've been using
elasticity is equal to percent change in
quantity over percent change in price
and over here no matter how much we
change price within reason at least
within this range of price along this
curve people are still going to demand 3
at a quantity of 3,000 vials per year
and let me just draw a let's just draw a
supply curve here so let's say the
supply curve looks something like that
and so if you have so this is supply so
if you have no taxes
no regulation of this market based on
the way I've drawn it right over here
the equilibrium price lens it's right at
around $75 and I did a little research
before this video it actually turns out
that is about the market price for a
vial of insulin in the equilibrium
quantity because that is the exact
quantity that people need is 3,000 vials
now a slightly interesting thing to
think about in this situation where you
have perfectly inelastic demand is what
is the producer surplus and the consumer
surplus so the producer surplus is how
much more money they're getting relative
to their you could view them as their
opportunity cost or their incremental
marginal cost and here we've done it
multiple times this is the producer
surplus right over here it's the area
between the price is equal to the
clearing price and our supply curve so
that's our producer surplus producer
surplus and our consumer surplus is
where things get a little bit
interesting consumer surplus is how much
more marginal benefit people are getting
than what they are paying and we've
traditionally said okay that's the area
between the demand curve and the and the
price but now all of a sudden this area
this area is infinite this area is
infinite and one way to think about it
is that these diabetics get you could
almost a close to infinite marginal
benefit from that insulin it allows them
to have a healthy life it allows them to
stay alive so for them it's essentially
priceless but it's kind of an
interesting idea that you have infinite
consumer surplus it's not necessary
saying that this is like a great deal
for the diabetics it's really just
saying that their their benefit is
something that they need to survive if
this was just slightly more elastic so
if we were to get maybe to a slightly
more real-world scenario in a real world
if things got a little bit more
expensive there might be a few diabetics
who would all of a sudden try to lower
their dose or something like that and so
the curve in a real world actually might
have some very slight elasticity would
still be a very steep slope but it would
actually have some slight elasticity and
so you can imagine if I kept taking this
up and up and up then at some point it
actually would bound the area but it
would so maybe it goes up here maybe you
know if this was like two million
dollars up here then the demand would go
down dramatically but it would be
bounded but it is a very very very large
consumer surplus now with that out of
the way let's think about what happens
if some misguided
Titian decides to tax insulin obviously
a very bad idea and nothing that I would
ever advocate but let's think about who
would bear the burden I think you could
probably guess who would bear the burden
if you had to put a tax but we'll
actually see it we'll think it through
with our with our supply and our
perfectly inelastic demand curve so what
X ends up getting passed is a tax of ten
dollars per vial and I'm just making it
instead of a percentage I'm just doing
it as a fixed amount so that we get kind
of a fixed shift in terms of the
perceived the perceived supply price so
for the producers this is what they need
to get if you want them to produce 3,000
vials they need to they need to get 75
dollars if you want to make get them to
even produce that first vial they need
to get sixty dollars so what the
producers need to get plus the tax we
can draw a new curve and we've done this
multiple times so for that very first
file the producer needs 60 but then what
the you add the tax there it's going to
be $70 for one thousand miles it looks
like it's going to be I don't know 60
something you add the tax it's going to
move move up to here for 3,000 vials the
producers need around seventy five
seventy six dollars you add 10 to it it
gets to 85 $86 like that so what you get
is this new curve new curves you could
view this as a price from the from the
consumers point of view or you could
view it as as the supply plus tax curve
so I'll call this the supply supply plus
tax plus tax curve that's hard to read
but that's as tax right over there this
is the supply plus tax curve and so
where does that intersect our perfectly
inelastic demand curve well you can
imagine people the even though the
prices are higher people still have to
get exactly 3,000 vials per year and so
they intersect right at that quantity
but now we have a new equilibrium price
our new equilibrium price is exactly ten
dollars higher and so it is it is about
if this was 75 or 76 this is 85 or 86 so
this distance right over here this
distance right over here is 10 so let's
think about a few things let's think
about the total revenue that the
government is going to get in this
situation so the total revenue is going
to be that $10 times the 3,000 vials per
year times 3000 so they're going to get
$30,000 $30,000 per per year now let's
think about who's whose surplus that
came out of so the tax revenue this
right over here is the tax revenue that
right over there is a tax revenue the
producers are still going to have the
exact same producer surplus so all of
that all of that tax revenue came
directly out of the consumer surplus now
another thing another interesting thing
to note here is because we had this
perfectly inelastic demand that even
when you raise the price it didn't lower
the quantity demanded that we actually
don't have a deadweight loss here
because this was perfectly inelastic
we're actually having the same quantity
produced and so the you some of you have
a transfer of surplus from essentially
the diabetics to the government in this
situation but you don't have any lost
surplus here because there's not there's
no there's no there's no lost area I
guess you could say between between
where the supply curve and the nd
between where the supply curve and the
demand curves intersect or another way
to think about it is the quantity
demanded did not go down because the
price went up